[Applause]
I appreciate you putting on a brave face
I I know you must be crestfallen because
Bill DeBlasio was dropped out of the
presidential race
he said I'm married with two kids I can
stay home and not be taken seriously so
also a Brett Kavanaugh his penis is back
in the news
oh yeah the New York Times kind of
tripped over his dick on this one they
reported about a guy in beckoned is
yelled a he's a long time ago who Bret
was at a party took his penis out and
his friends pushed it into a girl's hand
as friends do problem of problem is the
woman the victim has absolutely no
recollection of this ever happening
which is not exactly a ringing
endorsement of your penis more on that
later
President Trump was here in LA this week
what what's the net rate for a see
secret meetings with donors I love the
Republicans out here they always say
that they're not ashamed to be
associated with Trump and yet when he's
here they come and go by tunnel you know
that you never now Trump came to
California really for two reasons
raising money and also he's made a big
issue of the homeless right we have a
homeless problem out here worst in the
nation and Trump is gonna do something
about it
he says the homeless destroyed cities
okay it is a problem they don't destroy
cities a Starbucks restroom yes I've
seen that I've seen they destroy that
and now for this week's if Obama did it
he'd be impeached by now okay the day
following this is all over the news say
the whistleblower scandal we have a
whistleblower scandal some yet anonymous
member of the intelligence community is
was apparently so alarmed over the
summer when he saw Trump do something
say something to a foreign leader that
he reported it to the inspector general
that's who you'd go up the chain too and
it was labeled of urgent concern that's
a designation and of course when it's
that important they take it up to the
Director of National Intelligence and
under federal law the Director of
National Intelligence it says shall
deliver this report if it is of urgent
concern to Congress what the Director of
National Intelligence he says he's not
going to do that citing the old statute
go [ __ ] yourself
now there are a lot of facts we don't
know about this like who the
whistleblower is we don't know that but
we just know that it's someone who finds
Trump's behavior a threat to America
which narrows the list down to everyone
everywhere we do know the country that
is the country that Trump was talking to
apparently Trump was talking to the
president of the Ukraine and he was
threatening this man that he would
withhold military aid which we'd be
giving them unless this man investigated
Joe Biden because Biden's son was there
doing some business on a bogus charge
with Joe Biden the sons so here's what
we have a US president now is using
taxpayer money to pressure a foreign
government to smear his political
opponent it's it's not enough that Trump
has Russia meddling in the election now
we've invited Ukraine in for a three-way
we save you some time and an emotional
investment in this scandal because I can
tell you how this is about to go down
okay right now we are at the denial
stage we didn't do it then we go to okay
he did it but it wasn't bad then we go
to okay it was bad but it wasn't illegal
but it was okay it was illegal but not
when Trump does it then we go to that
we're gonna subpoena you stage and then
the aforementioned go [ __ ] yourself
finally landing at the Democrats oh well
we tried actually we did this today he
said is anybody dumb enough to believe
that I would say something inappropriate
to a foreign leader is anybody is
anybody dumb enough I think we have
found the new chant for the rallies is
anybody dumb enough do you think I do
something crooked and stupid yes but you
lost us at think part of it
the presidents of the Ukraine recently
elected is a comedian
did you know that the pretty is a
comedian for five years he was doing a
comedy show called servant to the people
where he played the president of the
Ukraine and he waltz right from that job
into being the real president of the
Ukraine imagine that what a fucked-up
country that must be yeah for once
America though this week not the only
country that's embarrassed Canada many
Canadians here had a very very very
rough week for you folks breaking news
we have her tonight someone has found a
picture of Justin Trudeau not wearing
blackface yeah it started to go Tuesday
they found an 18 year old photo of
Justin Trudeau the Prime Minister of
Canada in what they are calling Brown
face because he was dressed as Aladdin
for an Arabian Nights theme party and
now he is on the Liberal Party [ __ ] list
and on Trump's no-fly list
so then justin trudeau of course started
apologizing to everyone brown people
black people muslims genies but it's
like every time he went to a party you
know the shoe polish would come out it
was his version of brett Cavanaugh's
dick you know i finally a friend of his
you know you can also use that on shoes
but ya know Trudeau said this is just
not look good he said he can't really
say how many times he got into blackface
I mean as political excuses go that's
right up there with I thought she was 18
and now everybody you know is just
looking through their yearbook you know
fine and I must say I'm gonna get this
out in the open I did something terribly
embarrassing that is in my yearbook my
yearbook quote is from Peter Frampton I
just want that out there no III tell you
folks I have played it safe this
Halloween I am going as a self-loathing
albino
you